Welcome back.
I'm now going to do some more
examples of a bit of a review
of some of the derivatives
that we've been seeing.
And then I'll introduce you to
something called the chain rule
which expands the universe of
the types of functions we can
take the derivatives of.
So in the last presentation, I
showed you how to function if I
had f of x is equal to 10x to
the seventh plus 6x to the
third plus 15x minus
x to the 16th.
To take the derivative of this
entire function, we take just
the derivatives of each
of the pieces, right?
Because you can add them up.
So f prime of x in this
example, is equal to-- and
I think you get the hang
of it at this point.
It's actually fairly
straightforward.
We take the 7, multiply
it by the 10.
So we get 70x, then
1 degree less.
So 70x to the sixth plus
18x squared plus 15.
We can kind of view this
as x to the 1, right?
So it's 1 times 15
times x to the 0.
Which is 1.
So that's just 15 minus
16x to the 15th.
And I don't want you to
lose sight of what we're
actually doing here.
What is f prime of x?
This is the function the tells
us the slope of any point
x, along the curve f of x.
It's a pretty
interesting thing.
Let me just draw to maybe give
you a little bit of intuition.
I don't know what the slope
of f of x really looks like.
And actually, let's pretend
like this isn't f of x.
Let's pretend like this
is just some arbitrary
function I'm drawing.
If this is f of x, just some
curve that does all sorts of
crazy things, f prime of x
tells me the slope at any
point along that line.
So if I wanted to know the
slope at this point right here,
I could use the derivative
function to figure out the
slope of the tangent line.
The tangent line is something
like that right there.
Or if I wanted to figure out
the slope at this point,
once again I'd use the
derivative function.
And it would tell me the
slope of the tangent
line at that point.
Which would be
something like that.
So it's a pretty useful thing.
And once I give you all the
tools to analytically solve a
whole host of derivatives, then
we'll actually do a bunch
of word problems and
applications of derivatives.
And I think you'll see that
it's a really, really,
really useful concept.
So let's move on.
I think you get the idea of
how to do these derivatives
of polynomials.
Let me erase this.
I'm actually using a
different tool now.
So I think it might
be a bit easier.
Let's see, someone
was calling me.
But you're more important so
I will not answer the phone.
I'm going to introduce you--
this tool doesn't have, I
don't think it has a
straight up eraser.
Actually, maybe let's see.
If I do it like this.
Oh let me see.
No that doesn't work.
Let me just erase like this,
the old-fashioned way.
You just have to bear with me.
And then once I finish erasing,
I will show you the chain rule.
This is good.
It feels like I'm a real
teacher with a real chalkboard
and a real eraser now.
This is a lot cleaner than a
normal chalkboard as well.
Bear with me, almost there.
I'll figure out a faster
way to do this over the
next couple of videos.
It's pretty sad.
I'm showing you how to do
derivatives in calculus, but
I don't know how to erase
a faster way than this.
There, we're done.
OK.
So now I'm going show you how
to solve the derivatives of a
slightly more complicated
type of a function.
It's actually not
more complicated.
It's just different.
So let's say f of x is equal to
2x plus 3 to the fifth power.
And I want to figure out
the derivative of this.
We're going to use something
called the chain rule.
Because one thing we could do,
we could just multiply out 2x
plus 3 to the fifth power.
And if you've ever done
that, you know it's a pain.
So that's not something
we'd want to do.
So we're going to use something
called the chain rule.
And I'm just going to give you
a bunch of examples before I
even show you the definition
of the chain rule.
Because I think this is
something that you just
have to learn by example.
So the chain rule just tells us
that the derivative of let's
say this function right here.
You take the derivative of the
subfunctions, and then you can
take a derivative of
the entire function.
I'll tell you that formally.
But I think when you introduce
it formally, it gets
more confusing.
So what I do, I just take the
derivative of 2x plus 3 first.
And actually let me use colors.
I think that might simplify it.
So I take the derivative
of 2x plus 3.
What's the derivative
of 2x plus 3?
Well you know that.
It's just the derivative
of 2x, which is 2.
And then the
derivative of 3 is 0.
So the derivative of
2x plus 3 is just 2.
And then I'm going to multiply
that times the derivative
of the whole thing.
And I just pretend like
2x plus 3 is just like
a variable by itself.
So then what's the derivative
of x to the fifth?
Well the derivative of x to the
fifth-- I'm going to do that in
a different color-- the
derivative of x to the
fifth is 5x to the fourth.
So it'll be 5 times
something to the fourth.
But here we didn't take the
derivative of x the fifth.
We took the derivative of
2x plus 3 to the fifth.
So we just put the 2x
plus 3 there instead.
So what did we do here?
We went in the inside of
the function, and we took
the derivative here.
And the derivative of
2x plus 3 was just 2.
And then we multiplied
it by the derivative of
the greater function.
And we just pretended like the
2x plus 3 was a variable.
It was like x.
So instead of 5x to the
fourth, we got 5 times
2x plus 3 to the fourth.
And if we just simplify that,
f prime of x is equal to
2 times 5 is 10; 10 times
2x plus 3 to the fourth.
That was a lot simpler than
multiplying out 2x plus 3 to
the fifth power, and then doing
the derivatives the old way.
I know this was probably a
little confusing to you,
so I'm going to try to do
a couple more examples.
Let's say I had g of x is equal
to x-squared plus 2x plus
3 to the eighth power.
So g prime of x is going to
equal-- well what did we say?
We take the derivative
of the inside.
This is called the chain rule.
What's the derivative
of the inside?
It's 2x plus 2 plus 0, right?
And then we take the derivative
of the whole thing.
And we just pretend like this
whole expression, x-squared
plus 2x plus 3 is just kind
of like the variable x.
We know that the derivative
of x to the eighth is
8x to the seventh.
So it'll be 8 times
something to the seventh.
And that something is this
entire expression here, 8 times
x-squared plus 2x plus 3.
I hope I didn't
confuse you too much.
And you can simplify
this more in any way.
Because it's 2x plus 2 times
8 times x-squared plus 2x
plus 3 to the seventh.
To multiply this out, or
to multiply this out is
a huge pain as you know.
But we could simplify
a little bit.
Let me draw a divider here.
We could say that that equals 8
times 2x, 16x plus 16 times--
I'm making it really messy--
x-squared plus 2x plus 3
to the seventh power.
I hope I didn't
confuse you too much.
In the next presentation, I'm
just going to do a ton of
examples using the chain rule.
And I think the more examples
you see, it's going to
hit the point home.
And then after I've done a
bunch of examples, then I'm
going to give you a
formal definition.
I think that's actually an
easier way to digest the chain
rule than giving you the formal
definition first, and then
showing you a bunch
of examples.
So I'll see you in the
next presentation.